thank you
I'm sorry day6 it's 11:32 p.m. how was
your first day it was fantastic I
haven't seen cliff yet hey Dave where's
cliff really before the dogs in his bed
he's asleep and he's deaf so I can't
even wake him up she's deaf and sleeping
in her oh I'm sure she do you know that
dogs have no sense of time when you
leave and then come back and it was like
six hours to them it could be five
minutes all dogs have Alzheimer's
disease Michele's staying in the living
room we're actually in her room in my
bedroom
yeah I sleep there did you hear the
creaks the clanks the hisses you talked
about them in previous vlogs and so I
was able to expect them because you will
never expect a predator Wow oh my god oh
my god is she gonna like kiss me now
that is why I could never be an intruder
in anyone else's house they think I was
trying to hug them cute little girl
shank what's on tap for tomorrow I gotta
go to work you just said the mystery
word baby
sparkles what have you learned so far
from being at this house certain types
of people have very specific smells I
have thought that I've taken on actually
the smell of the dog but usually you
know you can't smell yourself but
sometimes you can and that's how you
know it's really bad yeah basically at
work I've taken the responsibility of
being the smelly girl in the office so
you're welcome
we're gonna cut that name out so uh